I want to take a steps a step like a
lateral step real quick from what we're
talking about when you you are in the
trenches of brutal combat running
through caves in Afghanistan or jumping
out of helicopters and you have yeah
like all the feel guys did that stuff
and and you have your night-vision
goggles on in the middle of the night
and you're running through a black
someone who blasted a hole in a wall you
said that you felt like you and your
fellow seals were just Souls next to
each other fighting against other Souls
and you you felt disconnected from your
bodies yeah can you can you explain to
me a little bit more what that means
when you describe that in words when you
when you really get into and you're just
doing that when you're in the midst of
it when you're in the midst of like
let's say this is like a football team
just say it's the soccer team let's say
it's anything else when you're in the
middle of that crucial that nast you
have ten seconds left and it's a tie
game and in that last play starts and
it's only gonna last for six or seven
seconds or ten or 15 seconds whatever it
might be that 15 seconds you make that
entire episode lasts for about an hour
where you start time starts to from
where you don't know where you are and
whatever is going and you don't you
don't see people anymore you just see
movement you see things happen you see
the world expanding in front of you kind
of in slow motion but critical does that
make a little bit of sense it just like
it's a blur just like everything you
just you just go on instinct and you
just go and it goin and you don't really
so if I looked over at David Goggins who
was in one of my platoons he was a he
was a new guy when I was chief I think
oh really yes I put him through a lot of
training he I'm in his book in a few
different places I think whenever he
talks about the chief a lot of times
he's talking about me in that book oh
wow I was the one I wasn't one in
Goggins book dad we have lockers we have
these huge lockers where you put all
your equipment
and I basically locked all their lockers
up and I made him live out of bag so
they had a bag of all their stuff in
front of this giant locker where they
could have spread out and organize they
cleaned everything up and they were
living out of like two bags I didn't let
him have a locker I said nah you're a
new guy
you don't deserve Locker you haven't
earned it and they go what do you mean
that's this messed up chief why do you
it's just like cruel and unusual
punishment you're such an [ __ ]
can I say [ __ ] you can say didn't ya
they dick call me an [ __ ] it was like
I was an [ __ ] and I told him I said
no just you live out of the bag and when
you guys have earned the privilege
didn't use that cage and the cage was
like six feet by six feet head hooks all
over and racks and you hang everything
up you can wash stuff down spread it out
you clean you can sleep in your cage
there big cages you can sleep in them
with hammocks which people do all the
time because we work so late sometimes
you want to catch an hour two hours of
sleep you do it in your cage you put
your hammock up and sleep your big cages
where you spread out your nice and
basically I made them live out two
backpacks you were second small I was
like dude you cannot have anything else
what you need is in those backpacks
organized I live out of them and they
did that for a while I came in right
along it was a few weeks sucked because
every evolution we had to go on they had
to repack them up and have them ready
and inspect them you know let's go
we have ten minutes get everything ready
to just go and all the old guys walk in
their big lockers and put everything and
put it together and it was easy because
you got everything spread out you could
see it all mmm so after three weeks out
of living out of a bag for David Goggins
I said all right put everything in the
lockers if you want to and organize your
stuff and get us spread out do we get to
do and they're like all right right on I
didn't like two days later they're all
spread out it's all good I said hey we
have 10 minutes pack up get everything
ready go and get in the truck and load
out we have to do a recon mission and
we're in the water get your fins get
your stuff it's gonna be really cold we
gotta get an airplane to fly out and do
a mission like all right so all those
new guys David Goggin include him
they were like everything's a bag and
they were in a truck waiting in like
three minutes and all the old guys are
gone what I need wait we need fins and
we're my freakin fins I got to do that I
get to get that I know the older guys
took three four times longer you know
why
because I made those guys live out of
the bags for three weeks they're
organizing it exactly what they needed
to have it all the extra stuff they had
a totally organized and ready to rock
and roll in a second notice all those
guys did but they walked into lockers
who had to pee grabbed a couple bags and
walked out they're sitting in a truck
waiting for everybody else
where was that where were you guys doing
this there was a SEAL team fire that was
when I was five but basically what
happens is we get lazy we get
disorganized we have the stuff we have
too much stuff I have three sets of fins
so I have to go which set of fins what's
the mission with that all the new guys I
had one set of fans they had one maps
hit everything said they had everything
there everything they needed
specifically how cold it's gonna be
what's the mission what's that convey
they knew exactly what to get boop boop
boop they're done we had to get on a
submarine with a hey we only enough room
for one bag everybody pack out one bag
to live on a submarine for a week and a
half to do these three missions and the
new guys were like zip zip zip
David gaga's everybody's ready they're
sitting on a truck waiting for all the
old guys because we had too much stuff
we were too disorganized we didn't know
what the brain we were like I mean it
didn't take forever they did it in like
two minutes it took us like ten minutes
it took us longer because we had too
much stuff it was a little spread out it
was like yeah so just get used to having
everything in a couple of bags be
organized the gretta to rock and roll
that's life life is like that when you
start to think about people living in a
tiny house or somebody downsizing or
somebody living in a freaking three or
4,000 foot mansion you say hey man
you're gonna be isolated out air you're
gonna do this you have to go camping for
a week pack up you have ten minutes the
person that lives in a 3000 foot mansion
has 15 pairs of boots and there's stuff
all over well we got a person that lives
in a frickin tiny house that's you know
200 square feet and it has only what he
needs it's a whole different way to live
yeah I think it speaks a lot to
practicing discipline well what was your
question
I can't remember what my I think no it
doesn't matter I think we were well
originally what I was trying to get at
was the analogy of you guys being souls
next to each other when you
they're fighting and it's uh was kind of
like a like like a flow state where you
just disconnected from your body and you
were just so tuned into that moment that
everything specific example that I just
talked about was me making all the new
guys live out of the bags
I said hey your new guys live out of the
bags learn how to do it did it matter if
you're black or white if you're Asian
Latino if you're European descent if
whatever you were did it matter no
you're a frickin new guy all of you live
out of the bags learn it equally when
they get to a level okay here's your
lockers all at the same time if somebody
wasn't getting it quick enough then the
other guys would help man we'd all get
up that level and so no matter who you
are what you are as a seal after two or
three platoons and after doing all these
deployments had to run two ton of
missions all that all the attributes of
you as a person kind of follow away
because you were all operating at such a
high level for so long you don't think
about you know yeah David Goggin is a
black dude and you know Kristin Beck I'm
gonna you know white I am a female now
it's like it doesn't none of that
matters because we worked so hard at
such a high level you don't think about
that stuff it doesn't count anymore
what counts is what you've been doing
for the team and how long you been doing
it and what's your position of the team
you're the quarterback I'm the lineman
we all work hard at the same level so we
all get up to that level doesn't matter
if I was a Christian Muslim if I was a
Buddhist if I was whatever none that
matters it matters what you are in the
team you're the quarterback your
alignment I don't care about any other
stuff oh you're a female who cares man
just you're part of the team and now
you're the you're the linebacker go be a
linebacker and if you're not a good
linebacker you're gonna get fired if you
can't do them 30 pull-ups sorry we'll
give you another shot but you failed
again you're off the team because we
can't have you there because you're
gonna get everybody else killed so
that's what it was like souls that's
what I was trying to get out okay was
that all the attributes of you as a
person
mm you don't see any of that anymore the
stuff that you see it's day-to-day in
America the prejudice against somebody
for being black or for being female or
being Latino happens a lot nowadays
for being Asia Asian so if you're from
Asia you're from Southeast Asia
you're from wherever you're from you see
prejudice every day yeah when you're in
combat
none of that stuff counts right and
especially from the time that that you
served what what year did you retire I
retired in 2011 2011 from the time that
yeah from that time when you were
serving especially until now I mean
obviously the 60s there was a huge
movement going on but between then and
now things have changed culturally as
far as like social justice warriors and
you know the way people react to
different things online and and the
division of politics has changed so much
let's get into social justice for one
second okay yeah let's do it so social
justice you know what does that actually
mean and it wasn't even something that
people worried about back in the 1950s
heck yeah and that's why we had some of
the movements we had so much stuff going
on but I want to relate to something
else in a second but then think about
politicians and everybody's yelling
about term limits and you're saying that
we need to have term limits because
these politicians have been in office
for so long and they're totally out of
touch with the people who do that and
that and so we already have term limits
it's called your vote every two years a
term limit for Congress person it's
already exists now because it guys a
good congressman er because everybody
loves somebody off of porn does that
mean that we as a people that don't live
in his congressional district we need to
say well the rest of the country doesn't
agree with your congressional district
and we want to go against what they
voted for and he shouldn't be able to
sort of past ten years now we already
have term limits every two years for
that guy now if all the people in my
district of voting for the guy then
that's what they that's what they did
and the same thing with social justice
do you think we have social justice I
think we have social justice just like
we have term limits for Congress people
we vote we go out we act we make stuff
happen but problem is is like the social
justice isn't uniformly distributed it's
there do you know what I mean and now is
it is it the right thing for us to
systematically or artificially flatten
the entire earth to me social justice
equal in Antarctica as it is equal in
South America or Chile or Argentina or
Russia or China or the United States or
Canada should we flatten all the justice
out across the entire spectrum of the
world against Auto spectrums of cultural
upbringing against all the spectrums of
religion religious freedom red eteri
against you name it
would that be fair
[Laughter]